swords can come in different shapes and
forms
and while some people think that they're
a bit overused can we help it swords are
just so cool aren't they
and badass too how many badass sword
wielders can you name
how many of them are protagonists of
their own shows that's what we'll be
talking about this time here are the top
10 most badass swordsmen mc's in anime
but before we begin
i noticed that not a lot of you viewers
are actually subscribed to my channel
if you've been here for quite some time
and liked a lot of the videos that i
post
i'd like to encourage you to hit that
subscribe button it doesn't take much
and i really appreciate the help that
you'll be giving this channel
now let's begin at number 10 we open up
with none other than our star members
is suffering in universe he just can't
get a break with that rough start he had
in the first chapters of black clover
out of universe
well the guy is unfortunately remembered
more for his hilariously conspicuous
shouting when the anime first began it
overshadowed most of what the character
has been able to do since then and trust
me
there's a lot of them arster has shown
an astounding amount of growth in the
series proper as expected out of a
shonen protagonist who's pretty much a
modernized take on naruto in a magic
world you could have dropped black
clover early on
but come back around the hundredth
episode or so and you'll suddenly be
bamboozled whoa arstar is so cool now
asked like such a badass who can do all
those moves now
hell yeah character development in play
and that's what makes him one of the
most badass swordsmen main characters in
anime
someone known as the son of the devil
himself should already be a candidate
for the next badass sword-wielding
protagonist on the list now with that in
mind
rin more than lives up to his billing
how can he not be when you take a look
at what he's capable of
let's see them blue flames inherited
from none other than the strongest demon
ever none other than his father high
speed regeneration and a heart that just
doesn't yield
finally a powerful sword that allows him
to harness his blue flames
in never-before-seen ways yep sounds
just about right for a badass anime
protagonist repertoire and he just keeps
getting stronger
both physically and mentally it's a
badass protagonist like this who would
have the guts to go hunting down his
father himself their fated confrontation
is one to look out for
and i'm sure that such a tough cookie
like rin wouldn't allow himself to just
bend over and lose
the shonen heroes just keep coming
stepping up for our next entry is
ichigo kurosaki
when you've got a local ghost menace in
town and prefers someone more human than
the son of the devil i think ichigo is
the right guy to call he's long wanted
to be your everyday guy just chilling
and keeping his friends safe
unfortunately when you get some amazing
ghost detection powers like he does such
a thing is nigh impossible when life's
got you in something like that
it is time to step up isn't it and step
up he did from the moment he got his
powers from rookier he's done nothing
but strive to become stronger in order
to protect all he holds dear that
includes trainings from hell
outright suicidal invasions of another
realm and taking in all the punishment
that comes with the tough battles that
he's had to go through despite not
really proactive as a character it's
just amazing how far ichigo can endure
when life's challenges come barreling
his way
truly a badass wielder of the sword
for a change of pace from shonen
protagonists we have the super vampire
slayer d
in our next spot
traveling across the lands in search of
vampires to hunt d
is an enigma handsome dark mysterious
and having godlike prowess
deeds the personification of noble
vampire's worst nightmares a lot of it
has to do with his background being a
product of a human and a sacred ancestor
little's known about dee's past but
given his outlook and his aura one can
tell that he's seen a lot
enough to make him the hardened and
tough hunter that he is oh and there's
also the thing about him being able to
become even stronger by accessing his
vampire powers it doesn't matter what
kind of being gets put in front of him
noble vampires aliens elder gods the
list goes on basically nothing can slow
him down or prove to be too hard of a
challenge for him he's no invincible
hero
but challenges rarely keep him down once
he gets you in his sights
he will cut you down that's just how
determined
and badass d is
a rogue samurai takes the next spot on
the list with mugen given his upbringing
it's really going to be surprising if
mugen wouldn't be on this list the
vulgar and aggressive samurai brings a
completely different dynamic to the main
trio in samurai champloo and i think
that in terms of being a straight-up
badass
is what everybody in the story beat
growing up in such a rough childhood
does that to you the young mugen had to
resort to crime just to get by and a
life where danger lurked to every corner
has sharpened him to be the tough
bastard that he is in the story proper
the strongest gems are forged from fire
and the life of anarchy has done more
than enough for mugen sure it puts him
at odds with a lot of people but that's
just what a good anti-hero is isn't it
he has a lot of astounding feats and
fights in the samurai shampoo proper and
i think those are more proof of how big
of a badass he really is plus who else
can fight so well yet so recklessly all
while showing off some dance moves
why don't we keep rolling with the
wandering samurai archetype now with
yakimaru
[Music]
if you think that mugen had a tough
childhood and a tough past you haven't
seen anything yet how about losing
practically your entire body to some
demonic pact out of your control and
having to slowly become
whole by fighting demons scattered
across the land while mugen had to
contend with ruffians and fellow
criminals kyakimaru had to deal with
problems of the supernatural variant
it's his story that makes doraro a very
exciting watch that i'd highly recommend
it doesn't follow the traditional weak
to strong formula that we've come to see
from anime often but it's such a thrill
to see the twists and turns in
hyakimaru's quest to become whole once
again you need no further proof of
hyakimaru's badassness then his
showcases of creativity and power in
defeating demons and slowly getting his
parts back
just imagine how tough those first few
fights are
let's make it three in a row now for
samurai characters shall we coming up
next is
afro samurai
just how badass is afro samurai don't
mind the fact that he's the second
strongest in the world for a second
being second strongest in the world is
no easy feat
but holding on to the titles against
fellow samurai
a copycat android and all sorts of
assassins at that is just straight up
bonkers but of course
number two just isn't the end point for
someone like afro samurai how can it be
when the previous holder of the title of
number one was his father and he had to
endure seeing his father killed in a
battle for the title thus
afro continues to forge forward even
with all the strength of the world at
his side he pushes on and keeps honing
his skills because he must seek revenge
no matter what blood-soaked road awaits
him
afro will stop at nothing to exact
revenge and take back the title of
number one that rightfully belongs to
his family
[Music]
a list of badass swordsmen main
characters wouldn't be complete
without kenshin anyone who grew up in
the 90s would no doubt be familiar with
the quiet samurai wearing an x on his
cheek kenshin's probably one of the more
iconic characters of that era not as
much as guys like goku but he's up there
and for good reason too starting off as
the cold-blooded killer kenshin story is
one of redemption it's a completely
enchanting journey as he goes from one
of the most notorious killers to finding
the warmth of love and friendship on his
road to erasing the person that he was
in the past even in his kindness
his skill with the sword hasn't dwindled
as you can see in the many big battles
he got in the series
ken shin as bato sai is a badass a true
demon on the battlefield who has no peer
but i personally think that the reformed
kenshin is even more badass there's just
something so cool with how composed he
is and how he sticks by his conviction
to never kill anyone it takes serious
restraint and some insane psychological
control because as we all know the
toughest battles are the ones fought
within us
[Music]
the runner-up this time is gintoki don't
let that cheeky and impish grin fool you
even the sweet tooth and the constant
laziness can catch anyone off guard but
what we're dealing with here is one of
the toughest sword wielder main
characters in anime that there is
yes this troll of a main character can
just as easily shift gears and amazed
with some of the most amazing feats for
an anime main character just trying to
count the number of times he saved
someone by arriving in the nick of time
how about the times he showed off his
swordsmanship skills that you wouldn't
expect out of a clown like him
you can even look at some of the gritty
slugfests that he found himself in
like the battles against dakasugi that's
not even getting to gintoki's tragic
backstories and burned bridges
he'd lost everything and he had a lot of
blood on his hands
things that he distanced himself from
even temporarily the man had long been
looking for a purpose
in life and as they say the biggest
smilers are in fact the ones who are the
most hurt ironically that makes him
quite a similar character to kenshin
just with a lot more mischief and
comedic elements
our number one badass swordsman main
character is none other than
guts ah guts if there's a character
who's the epitome of sheer toughness
grittiness
and plain old violence i think the guts
is a prime candidate for that
his backstory alone is one thing but
you're talking about a man who's grown
up completely surrounded by bloodshed
berserk as a series surely doesn't hold
back on the gore on the violence and you
have this one person hardened by such an
environment to not just survive in it
but thrive in it in the anime world guts
is truly the embodiment of brutality and
he's still getting stronger as time
progresses throughout the whole saga of
berserk rarely do you see him not being
able to just power and brute force his
way through the problems and that kind
of edginess really helped to make the
series such a cultural phenomenon in its
heyday now if only we could get a better
berserk adaptation than the one we just
had you know the one that became a meme
fountain due to the cg in terms of sheer
badassness i doubt that anyone would
come close to berserk's guts and he's
the undisputed number one character on
this list
[Applause]
[Music]
that's my list of top 10 badass
swordsmen protagonists in anime how does
your list look i'd love to know your
list so please share your thoughts on
the comment section below i think that
with a topic like this
we'll have a lot of interesting
character choices coming out i'm sure
that a lot of you would rank even my
list differently as always i'd encourage
you to subscribe before leaving and if
you enjoy the content you can share the
list to your friends to get them in line
with some awesome anime content i'll
have more lists coming your way so we'll
be seeing each other next time
see ya
[Music]
you